[Music]
hey what's up guys i'm kbhd here and if
you're like me you've probably watched
about every single other nexus 4 video
on youtube by now and i know that some
people will skip this video but i want
to bring this to you guys anyway so
thumbs up for that this is the nexus 4
unboxing and first impressions and the
nexus family just fyi is now complete
and that's a beautiful thing either way
here's what it looks like this is the
box and we're going to go ahead and dig
into it straight away after you cut the
tape and wiggle the top off bam there is
your nexus 4 right on top but we're not
done here we're going to go ahead and
move that to the side of course but i
can already feel the full weight of the
phone because the battery is in it
already of course and it does feel
pretty solid but behind this cardboard
you have a little bit of paperwork as
this quick start guide i might not ever
read that and below that sits the wall
adapter and actually a standard micro
usb charging cable and also included is
a micro sim card or tray ejector so you
can get your sim card in and out of the
phone and of course what unboxing
experience would be complete without the
removal of that protective shipping
plastic and this is about the cleanest
the phone will ever be right after you
remove these stickers for the first boot
it is pretty similar to what we saw in
actually my nexus 10 unboxing so if you
haven't already seen that the link is in
the description basically the first boot
is pretty quick flies right through the
google screen and then the nexus logo
right into the intro screen and then we
can go ahead and set up the phone for
the first time
all right first thing it's doing right
after i set up with my google account is
installing the latest version of android
4.2 jellybeans so i'm just going to be
patient and let this finish and we'll
get right into it android is now
upgrading on my apps and we are live and
this is android 4.2 jelly bean on the
nexus 4. all right so my first
impressions of the hardware of the nexus
4 are that first of all it is really
glassy as you can probably already tell
the nexus 4 has gorilla glass 2 on the
front and the gorilla glass 2 here on
the back
and overall it's a unibody design so
everything's sealed in so it does have a
pretty high quality feel and it's kind
of light but i wouldn't say it's a whole
lot lighter than the galaxy nexus but it
is a little bit lighter but uh on the
back you might not be able to tell it's
kind of hard with the camera angle but
it has a subtle design that's only
viewable from certain angles see how it
caught the light right there it has this
very clean look it's uh it looks like
it's textured from some angles but then
from other angles when you turn it the
other way it's clearly not textured but
it's overall a really cool look
but yeah obviously the hardware is brand
new internally you have that snapdragon
s4 pro which is just a performance
monster but that's all going to drive
this new software so go ahead and unlock
here this is android 4.2 jelly bean on
the new nexus now first of all you saw
when i unlocked and it gives me that
close animation but when i unlock on the
left and the right you see the outlines
for me to swipe and that's letting me
know i can swipe to get directly into
the brand new 8 megapixel camera which
from experience i've just played with it
a little bit
is really fast to focus and of course
when i open up again you can swipe to
the left to add some widgets to your
home screen of course you can swipe up
to google now or just unlock like a
normal person and there we go to unlock
into android 4.2
it comes stock with this pretty nice
live wallpaper out of the box which is
kind of cool
but basically the point of me doing this
video is to ask what you guys want to
see about the nexus 4 in the full video
review uh of course here's the quick
settings you can see here and the button
to go to the new android 4.2 quick
settings from the notification tray so
that's really cool i want to know what
you guys want to see i know that battery
life is an issue you guys want to know
what this 2100 milliamp hour battery can
do which is the same size that's in my
super nexus slash galaxy s3
uh but there are some other things like
performance and gaming that i will
definitely try to cover in my full
review so again thumbs up and plus one
if you're ready for that and uh that's
basically it so thanks for watching this
quick unboxing and first impressions
video of the nexus 4 and i'll talk to
you guys in the next video peace
[Music]
you